we are once again faced with the
combination of ignorance and arrogance
from Donald Trump
and it's always a perfect storm of what
I call weaponized ignorance around the
economy specifically remember when
Donald Trump called now criminal
national security advisor Michael Flynn
in the middle of the night to ask him
hey is a strong dollar or a weak dollar
better for the American economy Donald
Trump dealing with the economy is sort
of like you realize your car needs that
the transmission rebuilt and you bring
it to a guy who only knows how to
diagnose whether the car is out of gas
or not and often even diagnoses that
incorrectly you're not even going to be
able to assess the transmission with the
guy who can only read the gas gas
reading and that is similar to what is
going on with Donald Trump in the
American economy maybe a better analogy
is your engine blows and you bring the
car to a bakery the baker is equivalent
to Donald Trump dealing with the economy
it was a signal when Trump called
Michael Flynn and said is a strong
dollar or a weak dollar good that this
is not a guy who knows anything about
the economy and Donald Trump tweeting
yesterday quote Jay Powell and the
Federal Reserve fail again no guts no
sense no vision a terrible communicator
so to really do this correctly we've got
to go through it sequentially Donald
Trump has continued to just rage over
the idea that the economy would be doing
way better today if the Federal Reserve
would help him out with more and bigger
federal funds rate cuts in the way that
Trump believes they've quote helped out
previous presidents now Donald Trump has
gotten two rate cuts recently I believe
it was August first he got a 25 basis
point cut around August first
don't-don't-don't remember the exact
date and then he got another 25 basis
point cut yesterday 25 basis points is
like 0.25 percent but Trump is insisting
it's just not enough and the truth is
that both increases and decreases to the
federal funds rate can quote help a
president because the logic is if you
cut the federal funds rate it makes it
cheaper for banks to borrow money
and that can conceivably stimulate
economic activity and that will boost
the stock market and it will give
something to Donald Trump to brag about
how great the economy is doing but when
the federal funds rate is increased it
can also help the economy in that the
Fed must see the economy as being strong
enough to tolerate a rate increase
signaling that things must be going
pretty well so first of all it's not
even cut and dry that only rate cuts
helped a president look better in terms
of the economy that they are stewards of
but to analyze this outlandish behavior
by Donald Trump you also have to dig
deeper about in the modern economy does
a rate cut even really do the things
that we historically believed rate cuts
would do and the answer is only sort of
the the mechanism that is imagined for a
rate cut to help the economy is the
Federal Reserve cuts the rate this leads
to Americans buying more durable goods
like cars and stuff like that
interest rates drop on mortgages so
people will buy houses they will
refinance mortgages and save money and
have some extra money every month to
spend on other stuff but the reality is
that as the economy continues to
modernize the reality is of federal
funds rate cut of 25 or 50 basis points
is not going to have that significant
and effect people aren't saving up
waiting for a rate cut and then they go
out and they get a car and a house and
refinance spending has much more of a
natural cycle that's related to where in
life people are and and other factors
and in addition to that you've got to
remember that the bottom half of the
economy has had stagnant wages for like
40 years so a 25 basis point cut or a 50
basis point cut or a 75 basis point cut
is not going to stimulate any
significant amount of spending for a lot
of those people they just don't have any
money so the long and short of it is
that even this reliance on rate cuts to
quote jumpstart an economy or to prevent
a recession it's old thinking it's of
course based on the sort of economic
status quo that has not been good for
half of the country anyway that's a
bigger conversation and of course Donald
Trump is furious not only about only
getting another 25 basis points he's
furious that the Fed
predicting GDP growth of only 2.2
percent this year remember he was
promising 3/4 I think he even talked
about 5% GDP growth under his presidency
of course it's not happening it was
never going to happen and sadly the
Trump stuff around this is a really big
distraction from some bigger economic
questions that we don't have answers to
Trump is flat-out wrong about the
federal funds rate Trump is attacking
the federal the Federal Reserve chief
that he selected Jerome Powell I mean
it's crazy but it's a distraction from
what happens to the economy if we don't
deal with climate change isn't an
economy that is based on infinite growth
on a planet of limited resources
fundamentally a mathematical
impossibility
how good is an economy really even if
the stock market is high or unemployment
is low if half the country can't afford
an unexpected $400 expense or is one
illness away from bankruptcy there are
really important questions to solve
about the economy some of which we're
going to talk with progressive economist
Dean Baker later on today which I really
look forward to Donald Trump doesn't
even understand the problems nevermind
potential solutions and that's probably
the biggest tragedy of all of this make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there follow me at
David Pakman I people loving loving the
picture I posted with my dad's dog
yesterday
Nemo the English lab who is gone gray he
has a gray beard now not me the dog
follow me on instagram at david pakman
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show quick break back after this
hey really quick I want to tell you
about one of our partners Finch arrow
watches giving our audience 15% off
everything they offer these guys are
awesome they craft really stylish
top-quality watches for both men and
women but they sell them at a fair price
unlike a lot of their competitors Vinh
chero assembles their watches in small
batches which enables them to
meticulously ensure the quality of every
watch I personally wear of inch arrow
watch I don't like the idea of spending
thousands of dollars on a watch
when I can get a really excellent watch
for a hundred and fifty two hundred
bucks that's what I think is great about
VIN Shara you get a watch made from
top-notch materials they look like
watches that you'd spend a ton of money
on and they're built like high-end
watches designed mechanically with
longevity in mind but you don't have to
spend an arm and a leg their entire goal
is to make watches of superior quality
available to the average person I just
got a new one called the Kairos I got
the white and silver version
it looks great I've gotten a ton of
compliments they have a huge variety of
styles so it was easy to find one that
fits my tastes there are a bunch of
other companies out there selling
watches at similar prices but a lot of
them look very cookie cutter and just
don't offer the same level of
craftsmanship as what you get from bench
arrow you're not going to find a better
made watch at this great of a price
they've got a watch for any type of look
you're trying to go for formal more
casual the straps and colors are
interchangeable so you can customize
your watch to your own preference and
you can get 15% off everything in their
store when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch and use the code Pakman at
checkout